I am finally vertical again
after being under the weather for a couple of days.
I'm prepping some things tonight in the kitchen,
because tomorrow The New York Times is coming for an interview
and photographs and some recipe content.
So I'm getting things prepped for that and into the fridge.
The next morning, I realized that I needed some mustard
for one of my recipes that we were shooting today.
So I hurried and made some.
I added some turmeric to this,
and it turned out to be the most gorgeous bright yellow color.
I loved it so much. And then we got rolling.
They came, we started cooking.
They were photographing and interviewing simultaneously,
and I think it went well. Obviously,
you never know on these types of things until the article comes out,
but for me, it went well.
And then after that,
we did some photographs in front of the AGA and in the kitchen.
And then we were off for a farm tour LED by Daniel.
We went up to one of the lookout spots on the ranch,
and this is one of my favourite views.
So beautiful. You can see everything from up here.
And then we went to the dairy and met some milk cows.
We had some photographs with Daniel and the cows, and it was